Gabriel, how are you?
Good.
Always a pleasure to be here, Steve.
Okay.
Today I have the honor of the pleasure
of talking to my friend Gabriel
Silva, a fellow Vancouverite, a fellow
polyglot originally from Brazil.
And, uh, we're going to
talk about two subjects.
Uh, one why he's a polyglot, what
he gets out of being a polyglot.
And two to touch again on the subject of
that covered briefly with, uh, Leonardo
of Portugal differences between Brazilian
Portuguese and European Portuguese.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
Gabriel, uh, nice to see you.
I'm in Palm Springs.
Uh, with my fake bookshelf.
You're I think in Vancouver.
I am.
You are a very accomplished, uh, polyglot.
Uh, I have heard you in a number
of languages, unrelated languages,
Russian, Turkish, you name it.
What motivates you?
I know what motivates me,
but I want to hear from you.
And I think it'd be, it would
be interesting for my viewers.
What do you get out of being a polyglot?
Well, I love, I absolutely
love this question.
And, uh, right now I think that, you know,
the, my motivation goes through phases.
Uh, initially when I started really
learning and getting into languages, uh,
it was because it was just individually
attracted to different cultures.
So, uh, you know, it, it was,
I learned English and it took
me forever to learn English and
really get to a very fluent level.
And then I was just like, well,
I could, I seemed to really
suck at learning languages.
So I just want to actually try
to learn French and German.
Then I started learning
them at the same time.
And I, uh, I had a personal challenge that
I wanted to be, uh, cause I love Paris.
So I just actually, I lived
there for, uh, for a year.
I may go back.
I don't know when, and, um, I had this
personal challenge that I wanted to
communicate with Parisians in French.
And, uh, it also took me forever
to accomplish that, to, to get
to the point that my French was
decent enough for Parisians not
to switch to English immediately.
And, um, and then I was also really into,
I actually dated a German girl, um, and
then fell in love with the, with Germany.
So I just, I would go there and I
wanted to um, to learn German as
well, especially because it seemed
like such a difficult language.
So it was also a bit of a challenge.
So then when I, when I managed to learn
those languages and reach fluency, it
was just like, well, you know, like
I, now I know how to learn language.
So I just started going, you know,
getting into different ones and uh,
because I was attracted to Russian
literature, I thought like, why not
someday learn Russian so that I can
actually understand those stories?
And I thought it was going to
take me 20 years to learn Russian,
but it was quicker than expected.
And then I started getting into
Chinese and I started dabbling
into a ton of languages.
And then I found my, uh, an even
greater motivation, which is actually
something that I didn't, uh, originally
suspect would really happen, but it's
just how languages connect people.
And I, that's something that I, that
fascinates me so much because you know,
one thing that I absolutely love to
do, um, and this may seem random, but I
just, like, I always like to, you know,
strike up conversations on the streets.
Uh, I talk to random people like it was,
uh, I was in London for a little while.
Um, after I went, I lived  in Paris and
uh, it was just so much fun to just, you
know, start, start off talking to people.
And when you're a polyglot and you speak
these, like these different languages and
you, you know, you hear like whatever, I
hear some Chinese start speaking Chinese.
I would hear some, uh, Turkish would
be just like, oh, is that Turkish?
Oh, you're from Turkey.
And the barriers just disappear.
It's just absolutely insane.
How quickly they disappear.
I want to pick up on some of the things,
some of the themes that you mentioned
that I think are very important.
First of all, we become a
polyglot one language at a time.
Now we may study two languages at the
same time, but we begin by learning one
other language and then another language.
So at the beginning on the sort of
journey towards becoming a polyglot,
it starts with one language.
For whatever reason, we're
motivated to learn one language.
We're motivated to learn another language.
We realize we know how to do it.
We can do it.
And then it kind of snowballs.
That's very much been my experience.
The second thing you're saying
is that languages connect us.
And I think if we look at like, what's
the purpose of life, I think we are
never happier than when we are connecting
with other people and we can connect
with other people like in the here
and now or through books and movies,
and we can connect with people in far
away countries or far away centuries.
And so the opportunities
to discover human...
human beings, human activity
is, is so much enhanced by
learning different languages.
So the things that you mentioned
are absolutely, I totally agree
with what you have to say there.
Absolutely, and like that I, one
person that comes to mind is,
uh, Ari, uh, Xioma New York city.
Right.
And he, because he, uh, and
basically like I do, do some similar,
like similar videos, like in a
different kind of context really.
Cause I, um...
and he connects, he goes and he gets,
uh, an amazing reaction from people
because his Mandarin is so good.
And, um, and it's just amazing to
see how like, uh, barriers just like
absolutely dissolve between people.
But It's important in doing that to
make it about genuine communication
and not simply about performing.
Absolutely.
We have to make sure that we genuinely
want to connect with those people.
We don't want to just use them as a
uh, I'm not saying that Ari does that,
but I think it's very important to do,
to do this whole thing with respect.
One other thing I should say, uh, you are
a genuine polyglot, genuinely interested
in people, in literature, in so many
different things, but I should point
out that one of your major activities at
your YouTube channel you help Brazilians
with their English or other languages.
I'm not entirely sure.
And, um, you know, Brazil, people,
maybe don't fully realize that
like it's like the United States,
like it's 200 million people.
It's a huge country, a country
with, again, a mixture of peoples
from different parts of the world,
including the indigenous people.
It's a fascinating country
with tremendous potential.
And you're sort of, single-handedly
helping them overcome the obstacles
that language school has put in front
of them in terms of learning languages.
What are some of your messages
to your followers in, in Brazil?
I would say, you know, um, first one of my
messages we will, for sure, like, listen
to Steve, like check out his channel.
He's got so much incredible advice.
And second really is, you know, like
what I always say, just like um, take
language learning into your own hands,
and don't really just depend on the
little course that you bought and
that you're, that you're doing because
the language learning process is fun.
You should be engaged in it.
You should, um, get exposure to the
language as much as you can to do things
that you like, do things that you enjoy.
And, um, because a lot of students
really have this passive attitude towards
learning language, especially in Brazil...
it's changing now.
Not especially Brazil,
everywhere like it's...
Everywhere, everywhere.
Unless you live in Europe where
the neighboring countries speak
so many different languages.
In Brazil, that's less
motivation to learn I guess.
No, no...
but the thing is just like, I think
that, um, it's just because the, a
lot of residents are very, they have
have like a traditional mindset,
more orthodox way of thinking.
And, you know, there's nothing wrong
with that, but just like the mentality
is normally yeah like I'm just going
to go take a course to learn a language
and rely on that, rely on it and not go
that much further, but it is changing.
And like you said, yeah, it's,
it is a universal problem.
Uh, too many, especially, for
example, like in North America, first
thing that pops up when you say,
oh, Um, I'll pick up Duolingo or
Rosetta Stone to learn a language.
And that's just the way
that people think about it.
Normally like the average person, right.
If they, when it comes
to learning a language.
If they go that far.
Exactly.
Listen, one last thing.
Uh, we can talk forever.
We all know.
Um, so Brazil is this fascinating
country, 200 million people.
I'm not sure I have the stats right,
but it's around 200 million people.
Uh, and yet...
I think it's 210, maybe it's a very big.
210.
And Portugal in Europe is a much
smaller country, 10 million people.
But of course, for Europeans,
it's a much more likely tourist
destination than Brazil because
Brazil is that much further away.
Uh, North Americans may be
more likely to go to Brazil.
But for people who want to learn the
Portuguese language, how important are
the differences between Portuguese in
Europe, in, in, in, uh, Portugal or
for that matter Mozambique or wherever
else Portuguese is spoken versus the
form of the language or the different
regional forms of the language in Brazil?
How important are all these
regional varieties of the language?
Uh, I think that a lot of, uh, Portuguese
people may disagree with me, but I
would say that they're not that relevant
really in the sense that, especially
for instance, that that is a question
that I get for English all the time,
too, like, oh, should they learn
British English or should they learn,
uh, American English or Australian
English if I'm going to Australia?
I would say, learn English, learn
the language, um, and then really
worry about your, your specific,
uh, local accent or dialect later.
But of course that, you know, like
you may encounter some minor issues
if, uh, let's say you learn American
English and then you move to Scotland.
Um, then you know, they have a very...
That's an extreme example, but yeah.
You're in Glasgow and then like, you're
going to be struggling to understand.
Then of course you can get a lot of
exposure to content from that area to
just get acquainted with the accent.
And the funny thing too is just like,
for instance, just even in the UK
alone, there's so many regional accents.
Scouse is so different from, uh,
an, any accent from the south or
even the Jordie accent in Newcastle.
But anyway, so the Portuguese basically,
there is just so much, uh, content
in Brazilian Portuguese, really.
And in Brazil we have so many
also like different accents, uh...
so like basically, um, slang and
all sorts of different things.
But I would say learn the language.
And of course, um, Portuguese in
Portugal is very beautifully spoken.
It tends to be more formal.
Uh, of course they have their slang.
But, uh, often if you get exposure
to a lot of content from Brazil,
you may come across a lot of, uh,
local slang and things that are
going to be used in Brazil, but are
not going to be used in Portugal.
And there will be, you know, vocab
that's going to be different as well.
I love Portugal, I've been there twice.
And, uh, it was just very, very,
like, I'm fascinated, um, about like
the different little differences,
you know, like sometimes there'd be
just like a word that's just like,
oh, you guys say that, you know...
Yeah, but, but you're at a very high
level, obviously in all languages, but
in particular, in your native language.
I think the average beginner would
have trouble telling whether this is
Brazilian or Portuguese, wouldn't even
know, um, as is true with Spanish as
is true with all these other languages
that have different regional areas.
So you can't even hear the difference.
So beginners, shouldn't worry
about these differences.
They should just learn words.
And certainly when I was learning
Portuguese, I listened to
both Portuguese and Brazilian.
I want to be able to understand people,
uh, wherever they may come from.
And so I tend to feel that people
make too much of an issue out of this.
You know, which variety
are you going to learn?
Is this Portuguese from
Portugal or is it from Brazil?
You have to get pretty good.
You have to be well into intermediate
before you can even hear the difference.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I think that like, friend, I've heard
some people say like, oh, you know,
Portuguese from Portugal sounds more
like Russian to a foreign person versus
Brazilian Portuguese may sound more like
a, I don't know, like some broken form
of Spanish or whatever, like to whoever
doesn't speak the language or whatever.
But, um, yeah, I think that, you know,
Steve, you're absolutely right because
you need to learn the language then if you
just really want to focus on a specific
area, let's say that you're learning
Portuguese and then you want to move to
Lisbon or you want to move to Porto or,
uh, versus São Paulo or Bahia, you know,
you're going to, you can then later worry
about, uh, um, the regional accents, the
regional like slang way later in the game.
If you really don't know that
language yet at all, you may think
Portuguese sounds like Russian.
Once you know words, you're
more focused on the words.
And at that point, the
differences become less important.
If you don't know the language at all,
you would think that Greek and Casti...
iberian Spanish are the same
language because they have the
same sounds, the same sounds.
They don't have the same words at all.
But once you know the words, it's hard to
tell if the person is Mexican or Spanish,
because you're now focused on the words.
And overwhelmingly in Portuguese,
like from, from Europe or from
Brazil, it's the same words.
And it's the same grammar.
Period.
No more or less.
Yeah.
W well, I say like, obviously, you
know, the, the, the Portuguese, and
that's something that I've noticed that
in Portugal, for instance, they speak
very, they speak very elegantly, you
know, the, the Portuguese, they're very
proud of, of the Portuguese language.
And even like, for example, like
sometimes every now and then a Portuguese
person says like, oh, Hey, you know,
like, listen, this is Brazilian.
That's not Portuguese.
You know, th that's a different
language, but it's, it is the Portuguese
language, of course, that, you know,
there, there are many, um, you know,
differences, uh, in terms of specially
vocab in, in the, in the long run.
But when it comes to, when it
comes down to it, it is the
same language, essentially.
And it's the same thing, for example,
like, let's say let's take Spanish,
for instance, someone from Colombia,
normally the Colombian accent is
regarded as very clean and pure.
Um, they speak very clearly and so on.
So, and then if you take someone from
Chile, Chile has a lot of, uh, you
know, they have like a lot of um, slang.
They, they cut the words and
especially because they they're
more geographically isolated right
by the Andes and stuff, Andes?
I don't know.
Um, so then if you, but you know, if
you, if you're going to move to Chile,
you're going to learn Spanish anyway.
Then later you like, when you're, like
you said, when you're at an intermediate
level, then you're going to be, you know,
wanting to focus on the regional accent
and so on, but it is the Spanish language.
It doesn't really...
Trouble with Gabriel is that
we always agree on everything.
So on that point of agreement,
learn Portuguese, it's a wonderful
language there's I don't know, 250
million speakers around the world.
Just learn that language.
Don't worry about which version and
that applies to whether you're learning
Portuguese or Spanish or French or
English or Chinese or any other language.
Gabriel, as usual, I, we could
speak for hours, but maybe we'll
just stop it there and thank you
very much for coming on my channel.
Sounds good.
Always a great pleasure, Steve.